well hello there and welcome we have
many things to discuss today among them
Facebook under fire Democrats attacking
a children's book for no reason at all
and will technology kill us all I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
okay so I'm gonna do this I never do
this but I'm gonna take just one moment
event because let me tell you the last
24 hours
they've been garbaggio now listen I'm
perfectly well happy to be here in
Pennsylvania I'm speaking at Susquehanna
University tonight they're supposed to
be protesters people are very upset that
I'm coming yada yada that's how it
always goes the last night I had to fly
into Atlanta I know first world problems
but I get in there there in the middle
of a tornado warning and then I have to
stop at a hotel that let's just say was
not five-star it's the kind of hotel
where you wake up at two o'clock in the
morning and you really haven't gone to
sleep and you're just feeling like
garbage and you need some water because
there's no water in the room because the
last time anybody cleaned the room was
three years ago and so you saunter on
over to that that special vending
machine just down the hall you know
right past those three doors that people
have been slamming the entire night and
you know that the guy next door has been
listening to a gym keep watching a Jim
Carrey movie because you can hear
through the paper-thin walls anyway you
saunter on over to that vending machine
and you say you know what I'll get
myself some water and really chill out
and then you get to the vending machine
and you realize the only options are
coca-cola sprite and mello Yello and you
think to yourself did I somehow stumble
into a portal and then of course we have
the technological problems of today
shows but don't worry we have so many
things to get to actual real news not
just me being in mode but about the
situation let's just say that the high
life is not always what it's cracked up
to be but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at policy genius so
if you are like me and you are afraid of
death at this point in your life then
you might want to be looking over at our
friends at policy genius because policy
genius has made comparing and buying
life insurance easy for in 10 Americans
do not have life insurance that's
because they are not thinking ahead you
should have life insurance your families
should be insured in case something bad
happens to you they shouldn't be relying
on whatever meager pension you have
earned up to this point you should have
life insurance that's where policy
genius comes in they've taken over the
entire shopping process and brought it
online in just five minutes you can
compare quotes from over 15 life
insurance providers when you compare
quotes you saved money it is that simple
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance and placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage they
don't just insure life they insure
everything in it you can compare health
insurance disability insurance pet
insurance renter's insurance and if
you've been putting it off right now now
is the time for you to go and get policy
genius.com life insurance again
pause it go over do it you don't have to
worry about it ever again go to policy
genius.com get quotes applying minutes
it is that easy that rates are the
lowest they've been in 20 years policy
genius calm the easy way to compare it
and buy life insurance again that's
policy genius.com alright so the folks
on the ropes over the past 24 hours
have not just been world travelers you
know crossing the country it's also been
the folks over at Facebook so right now
the Federal Trade Commission is
investigating whether the use of
personal data from 50 million Facebook
users by Cambridge analytic Avaya lated
a consent decree that the tech company
signed with the agency in 2011 according
Bloomberg so if you recall all the way
back to yesterday's show there was a
report in the UK Guardian suggesting
that the folks at Cambridge analytical
which was the data analysis firm the
data gathering firm for the Trump
campaign that they hadn't listened
together 50 million Facebook users now
there's nothing illegal about what they
did apparently what they did is they
gathered a bunch of data from Facebook
users who had taken a personality quiz
and then they'd use those personality
quizzes they obtained that data they did
cross-reference that personality quiz
data with supposed politics and this was
a work of heart-rending genius right
this is what won Trump the election it
didn't when Trump the election by the
way Trump won the election because
Hillary was an unbelievably crappy
handed it and Trump campaigned in the
right places okay it wasn't because
there are a bunch of people who came for
general etiquette hacking your Facebook
data or anything like this this is just
nonsense if you've played farmville on
Facebook they're gathering your
information if you shop online they're
gathering your information ever wonder
how it is that the ads on your Google
are tailored to you right you just
bought something from Amazon and voila
there's another ad from Amazon that's
because everybody online is always
gathering information about you to make
sure that they can sell you things
that's how online works hey there's
nothing terrible that happened so far as
I can see yet maybe there will be new
evidence of something quite terrible but
the left is going crazy because again
they're trying to set up a particular
narrative here so a spokesman for the
FTC is saying quote we are aware of the
issues that have been raised but cannot
comment on whether we are investigating
we take any allegations of violations of
our consent decrees very seriously as we
did in 2012 in a privacy case involving
Google Facebook said Tuesday it receives
a letter from the FTC with questions but
had not been informed of a formal probe
if these were all found to be violations
if it turns out that Facebook had been
willfully violating its own consent
decree it would cost them $40,000 per
violation if you were talking about tens
of millions of violations then you're
talking about presumably billions
billions of dollars in violations you
basically bankrupt the company if this
ended up being a serious issue but it
really isn't okay these weekend reports
allege that Facebook users allegedly
willingly provided their data to a
psychology quiz app and then the people
who made that quiz that passed the data
along to Cambridge analytical without
the users knowledge constituting a
potential violation okay whatever that
is not a big deal I'm sorry I'm not
gonna pretend that I think that it's a
huge deal if firms that are gathering
data on you market that data at other
firms if this is how online works again
people who are ignorant about how online
works the reason that you are you are
seeing all those ads is because people
put cookies on your browser this is this
is all ridiculous
hey shares of Facebook fell five percent
Tuesday after skating as much as eight
percent on Monday and now apparently
Mark Zuckerberg having a meeting but
he's not going so Facebook's Bureau
they're their staff is having a meeting
the chief executive of Facebook
according to the Guardian Mark
Zuckerberg has remained silent over the
more than 48 hours since The Observer
revealed the harvesting of 50 million
users personal data even as this company
is buffeted by mounting calls for
investigation and regulation following
stock prices in a social media campaigns
who delete facebook Facebook shares slid
7 percent on Monday following the news
knocking 36 billion dollars off the
company's valuation as investors worried
about the consequences of the
revelations according to the UK Guardian
Zuckerberg owns 16 percent of the
company and he personally saw his
fortune fall 5.5 billion to 69 billion
oh poor baby can the embattled social
media company announced on Monday it
would engage in a digital forensics firm
to kondeh to conduct an audit of
Cambridge analytical to determine
whether the firm or not still has copies
of the data in question hey does this
sound like anything awful happen well
let you let you be the judge okay here's
the deal
okay for years all we heard after 2012
is that one of the reasons that MIT
Romney lost is because the data
operation for the GOP sucked I was there
I remember this was the talking point
the talking point is that MIT Romney did
not have the necessary data operation in
order to ensure that everything was
going to go okay okay and then in Barack
Obama's data team by the way was praised
as these wonderful world breaking
geniuses in fact flashback to 2012
Maxine Waters that another world
breaking genius she was talking back in
2012 about how Barack Obama had done it
and she said he gather data on everyone
via Facebook Wow
put in place an organization
that contains the kind of database that
no one has ever seen before in life
that's going to be very very powerful
and whoever the organizing for America
that he's now shifting to become a 501 C
4 yeah that's right that's right and
that database will have information
about everything on every individual in
ways that it's never been done before
and whoever runs for president on the
Democratic ticket have to deal with that
and yet no one found that creepy how
magical it's amazing it's like when
Democrats were engaging in micro
targeting and giant swaths of gated data
gathering everybody just looked the
other way
Wow I can't believe it in fact one of
the publications that looked the other
way not only look the other way but
praised the Obama campaign was you guess
it the UK Guardian in 2012 they reported
that President Obama's re-election team
was quote building a vast digital data
operation that for the first time
combines a unified database on millions
of Americans but the power of Facebook
to target individual voters to a degree
never achieved before whoa I mean that
sounds exactly like what Trump's team
was doing oh my goodness that must have
been nefarious then but no it was about
about the Guardian talking about the
world breaking genius of the Obama team
again building a vast digital data
operation that for the first time
combines a unified database on millions
of Americans with the power of Facebook
to target individual voters to degree
never before achieved
according to the Guardian Obama's new
database would be gathered by individual
volunteers who to log on to Obama's
re-election site using their Facebook
credentials consciously or otherwise
okay again the entire claim here is that
the Trump campaign gathered data on
people who weren't consciously aware
that their NATO is being gathered here's
the Guardian in 2012 quote consciously
or otherwise the individual volunteer
will be injecting all the information
they start publicly on their Facebook
page home locations date of birth
interests and crucially network of
friends directly into the central Obama
database Facebook had no problem with
any of this but they do now there's a
reason for this again the former Obama
director of integration and media
analytics said during the 2012 campaign
Facebook allowed the Obama team to quote
suck out the whole social graph Facebook
quote was surprised we were able to suck
out the whole social graph but they
didn't stop us once they realized that
what what we were that was what we were
doing and then this is this woman added
quote they came to the office in the
days following the election recruiting
and were very candid in
they allowed us to do things they
wouldn't have allowed someone else to do
because they were on our side not so
with Trump of course as soon as Facebook
realized the Cambridge analytic I had
pursued a similar strategy they
suspended the firm none of this is
surprising because it's all part of a
larger and greater agenda that larger
and larger and greater agenda as I
suggested yesterday is that Democrats
think that Trump should not have won in
order to prevent future Trump from
winning they're going to prevent
conservatives from getting out their
message they're going to prevent data
mining by Republicans but they will
allow it for Democrats they're going to
prevent conservative websites like The
Daily wire from distributing our
material they'll build algorithms to
prevent that distribution
they'll similar that they will at the
same time benefit a bunch of left-wing
organizations that are doing exactly the
same kind of journalism that we are just
on the other side Democrats have been
using the Trump election as a way to
browbeat social media companies that
were supposed to be open sources into
censoring conservatives that's what this
is all about that's the agenda here the
agenda here has been clear for months
the agenda here is the Democrats who
have been claiming with no evidence
whatsoever that it was social media
manipulation that won Trump the election
and therefore Facebook YouTube Google
Twitter these all have to be regulated
he's off to be brought to heel this is
specifically designed to cause the heads
of those firms who by the way are all
horrified that Trump won write
Zuckerberg is horrified and Jack Dorsey
at Twitter is horrified the heads of
Google Eric Schultz he was part of the
Obama team all the people at Google were
horrified right nobody at any of these
companies wanted Trump to win and they
don't want any part of being blamed for
Trump winning so they're using this as
an impetus to basically censor
conservatives this is the next step so a
year and a half ago there was a lot of
talk about Facebook algorithms
preventing conservative topics from
trending and Zuckerberg met with a bunch
of conservatives including my friend
Glenn Beck and he believed Tucker
Carlson a bunch of people and to talk
about shifting his algorithm and
according to Wired that was all an
attempt to sort of buy off the press
prevent conservatives from whining about
it too much well now they don't care
whether conservatives whine about it
they've just decided they're gonna cater
to Democrats by essentially shutting
down all these mechanisms for
conservatives Senate Democrats have
trotted out a bunch of pathetic Russian
created memes on Facebook viewed by a
handful of human beings right and as an
excuse for Hillary Clinton's loss
they've suggested that this is why
Hillary Clinton lost those things we
showed them on the show they're pathetic
never seen by five people they spent the
Russians in the entire election cycle on
Facebook so don't spend something like
$100,000 on Facebook you know
honest-to-goodness small companies spend
tens of thousands of dollars a month
marketing on Facebook that was a giant
nothing burger but the Democrats are
claiming it to something burger because
of course they want to use that as an
excuse to Club all of these social media
companies into submission they also
claimed without evidence that fake news
had swamp Facebook we've heard nothing
about nothing but fake news for two
years now
Oh Trump only won because of fake news
because people are reading headlines
that weren't real we've had article
after article about this the problem of
fake news what the Democrats mean by
fake news is news that is slanted to the
right right commentary that is slanted
to the right interpreted to the right
they don't like that stuff not just
stuff that's outright false nobody likes
the stuff that's outright false but
instead of just banning the stuff that's
outright false
Mark Zuckerberg has gone further right
Mark Zuckerberg has decided that he is
going to cleanse his network of all
stuff that would remotely be construed
as conservative in February Wired
magazine ran a cover story specifically
dealing with Facebook's role in the
election of 2016 and their subsequent
attempts to fix the problem after the
election Zuckerberg the head of Facebook
met with Barack Obama after the election
when Obama was no longer the president
and he met with Barack Obama I'll tell
you in one second what exactly he said a
Barack Obama because it's stunning and
it shows that what I'm saying about this
quasi conspiracy theory is not a
conspiracy theory this is all out in the
open I'll explain in just a second first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at zip recruiter so if you're
having a rough day at the office and
let's say that your employees haven't
been doing a particularly good job you
need to replace all of them well the
place to go is zip recruiter com
there you go to zip recruiter and zip
recruiter com is where you go and when
you go there you can post your job
offers and 80 percents of employers who
post a job on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day zip recruiter learns what
you're looking for identifies people
with the right experience and invites
them to apply to your job in zip recruit
it doesn't just stop there they even
spotlight the strongest applications you
receive so you never miss a great match
we use a recruiter here at the office
for daily wire we may use it after
today's show depending on how the
technical specs go the rest of the day
the right candidates are out there zip
recruiter is how you find them right now
my listeners can try zip recruiter for
free go to zip recruiters comm slash
daily wire that zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire again in zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire you use that daily
slash daily wire number once they know
that we sent you a number too so you can
try zip recruiter for free you can post
your
job unzip recruiter comm slash daily
wire for free zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire it's the best way
to upgrade your business so go check it
out okay so what exactly did Zuckerberg
meet with Obama about here is what
Zuckerberg met with Obama about hey you
ready after you the election
Zuckerberg met with Obama in an attempt
to convince Obama he was serious about
stopping the misuse of the platform by
misuse supposedly this meant fake news
and Russian intervention really what it
meant is that Obama and the rest of the
left were suggesting that Republicans
had gotten good at social media because
guess what we have a we at Daily wire
are very good at social media we have a
social media team we have people who
work on Facebook every single day and
Facebook decided they wanted to quash
everybody right this is there this is
their goal in February Zuckerberg said
he wanted to rejigger the algorithms on
his platform to benefit content that
Facebook deems trustworthy informative
and local there's the translation
trustworthy informative in local that
means Democrat Democrat and Democrat
Wired celebrated court you can't make
the world more open and connected if
you're breaking it apart so what was the
result of Facebook's algorithmic news
change conservatives have been
absolutely destroyed a study from the
Western Journal found conservative sites
have lost an average of 14 percent of
all their Facebook traffic left his
sights on average cite minor increase
and this even held true for major
publications not stuff like The Daily
wire but two of the New York newspapers
right the New York Daily News saw a bump
rides the left wing will outlet they saw
a bump of nearly 25 percent in facebook
traffic the New York Post they dropped
12 percent that is the goal here that's
the entire goal this isn't really in any
serious way about anything except for
forcing social media platforms to move
to the left and social media wanting to
demonstrate just how wonderful they are
by moving to the left in order to head
off Democrats and make themselves feel
better about the fact that Trump was
elected president that's all this is
there's a reason that Twitter has
suspended all right racist but continues
to promote Louis Farrakhan there's a
reason that YouTube is being sued by
Prager University for D monetizing all
of its videos there's a reason that
Google used to automatic fact-checking
on right-wing sites like this when we
discussed it on the show but did no such
thing
for left-wing sites is a radical
rejecting in social media the reason I
use Facebook the reason I use Google the
reason I used YouTube the reason I use
Twitter is because these are open
sources because the whole goal here is
that these were neutral arbiters these
were not people who are going to
interpose themselves between you and the
news you want to see I'm
emails every single day from users over
at Facebook we're saying that we used to
chop in their newsfeed and now we no
longer do and they want to know how to
fix it we have a video by the way over
at YouTube and Facebook where you can
see how to fix your newsfeed so you're
actually getting our headlines again but
the goal here is very obvious there's a
reason Democrats are gonna continue
focusing on nonsense stories like the
Cambridge analytic a story it's all
about creating a cloud cover so that
creating a base of fire so that the so
that to suppress conservatives that's
all this is its suppression of effect
it's a suppression attempt against
conservatives on all of these major
social media outlets and here's going to
be the final solution on all this the
end solution here is going to be either
regulation of these companies or
beginning new companies I think
beginning new companies is probably
gonna happen in relatively short order
I've heard rumors to that effect from
some pretty major folks that there will
be rivals to YouTube there will be
rivals to Facebook that that these
companies in their attempt to shut down
free and open exchange of ideas in their
attempt to prevent views that they don't
like from being disseminated they're
driving away a huge percentage of their
audience and this is really important
stuff because so many people get their
news from Facebook right now it's like
well over 50 percent of the of the
people in the United States get their
news from Facebook well Facebook is
censoring us but not censoring the New
York Times you're only getting one
element of the news and again one
elements of the news and that's really a
scary thing and they shouldn't be
policing how you receive information
this is the same thing they're doing on
campuses by the way when they say that I
shouldn't speak the D platforming is the
way of preventing dissent they can't
debate us they don't want to have
conversations so instead they just say
well you must be cheating somehow you're
doing something so nefarious that we
can't even let you anywhere close to the
to the free and open exchange of ideas
get out of here is this scary stuff it
should be scary stuff at least for
Americans who are worried about leftist
overreach because it come on I mean this
is just it's just bad stuff okay now
speaking I've leftist overreach in
general leftist nastiness so yesterday
we played an interview that I did with
Charlotte pence Charlotte pence is the
charming 24 year old daughter of the
vice president of the United States mics
in States Mike Pence and Charlotte had a
new book they came out and her new book
was about her bunny okay the the it was
called Marlin Bundys day in the life of
the vice president very innocent very
nice book I read it's my four-year-old
daughter it's very charming it's a
political Charlotte is not a political
player her sister is not really
political player her brother is not a
political player you know Mike Pence is
political that doesn't mean that his
kids are political that doesn't stop the
left so John Oliver who has apparently
decided to make a living out of being an
insufferable douchebag hey he came out
on HBO and not only ripped pens he then
launched a rival children's book against
Charlotte pence his children's book
about a bunny because this is how nasty
so many of the folks on the Left have
become now while in many ways pence is
like any other Trump employee ethically
compromised creeps the cowboy jared and
subjected to all sorts of unwanted
physical contact
pence is constitutionally the only
official in the White House that Trump
can't fire the first tell-all book to
come out of the current White House is
hopping into bookstores Marlin bundo the
pet rapid a vice president Mike Pence
there we also wrote a book about Mike
Pence's Rapids that has also been
published in fact right now okay and the
book that they created was a day in the
life of Marlin bundo and this book is a
book about a gay bunny who's being
victimized by a creature called stink
bug who's supposed to be drawn like Mike
Pence because of course Mike Pence hates
gay people again I'm waiting for the
evidence that Mike Pence hates gay
people but people on the Left just keep
suggesting it over and over so I suppose
it must be true now what's even worse is
that john oliver then sicked all of his
friends onto onto charlotte Pence's
amazon page so her Amazon page got
spammed with nasty reviews so not from
people who had actually bought all of
the had actually bought her book but
from all of the people who were buying
John Oliver's books they all went over
there they spammed her site with a bunch
of one-star reviews on a nice friendly
apolitical children's book okay this is
the charming left they have to attack
Mike Pence's daughters children's but
now what's amazing about this is that
Chelsea Clinton wrote a children's book
also the right basically left it alone
okay her children's book was an openly
political book it was called she
persisted it wasn't a book about like an
animal in the White House and here's
what the Vice President does all day it
was a book about how Hillary Clinton
persisted and women persist and girl
power and all this kind of stuff right
that was political the right basically
left it alone because hey it's Chelsea
Clinton should we really make a big deal
out of it okay the left could not even
leave alone a book about a bunny
they couldn't even leave alone a book
about a bunny because
so much of the left's viewpoint is now
consumed with the idea that if you
disagree with them that you are a bad
person that you are a terrible awful no
good very bad person so I'm supposed to
speak at Susquehanna college tonight and
one of the things that I want to talk
about is exactly this this this tendency
on a part of people on the left to
attribute nasty motivations to people on
the right we've seen it throughout the
gun debate by the way I've seen it over
and over throughout the gun debate
actually but it's not just with regard
to the gun debate I mean we'll show you
one clip with regard to gun debate so
here is David Hogg who's become again
just insufferable he's one of these
parkland students obviously again for
the one millionth time I feel terrible
that he witnessed tragedy but here he is
talking about politicians being the this
is his words the because of the NRA what
if our politicians weren't the bit of
the NRA it doesn't make sense that I
have to wait till I'm 21 to get a
handgun but I could get this weapon what
if we all voted and said this is not
okay it was an incredibly exciting
election night in a district there never
should have been a question that the
Republicans should have won they're
sending a Democrat from the heart of
Trump country voters okay so now David
hog is is openly stumping for he's
openly something for Democrats in the
way he's doing that is by claiming that
everybody who disagrees with them is a
the NRA if this sort of talk is not good
for the country it doesn't allow us to
have conversations with one another
there's an open letter written by a
student at Susquehanna to me upon my
speech tonight and it's just again
astonishingly stupid okay here is what
this this guy writes he's a student over
at Susquehanna college and he's doing
this at Susquehanna University and he's
doing the same thing his name is no one
at Nightingale and and in just a second
I'm gonna read you what Nolan
nightingale has to say about me arriving
at Susquehanna because obviously I'm a
bad guy because we disagree and I will
show you that this is how he feels and
again this is terrible for the country
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at movement watches so
movement is just fantastic they don't
just sell watches by the way they also
sell sunglasses so this watch right here
this is a movement watch it is
magnificent okay you can see it's
cleanly designed it's a beautiful watch
but not just that now they have
sunglasses
okay so I've gotten a bunch of pairs of
sunglasses before and every time I buy
an expensive pair of sunglasses I feel
like I got ripped off well the folks
over at movement thought exactly the
same way so that
screw it how about we make quality
trendy sunglasses at a fair price I have
a pair of these sunglasses either it
made of acetate you can get them
polarized they start at just 70 dollars
these are my go-to shades they are
awesome they're classic looking just
like everything else to make the
watchtower classic looking their
sunglasses are classic looking they just
have high quality products all the time
high quality premium acetate frames no
cheap plastic you do have to go check it
out they have a bunch of different
styles get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns when you go to
MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro that's MVM
t.com slash appear again MVM t like
movement comm slash apparel use that /
apparel so you get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns you know
movement for how they revolutionize the
watch industry you like these watches
right I know that so many my fans have
already gotten these watches for family
members now go get the sunglasses as
well it's MVM t-dot-com slash apparel
MVM t.com slash shapiro for that special
15% off deal join the movement today ok
so here is the letter from this student
over at Susquehanna University warning
the rest of the campus an open letter to
me personally so I will respond
personally here's what he says dear mr.
Shapiro I'm a student at Susquehanna
University and a proud one at that if
that name sounds familiar to you it's
because you are scheduled to speak here
on March 20th of this year you were
invited by the Young Republicans Club a
young group of people who are by all
means reasonable and relatively nice
I've grown up with around Republicans
all my life my parents whom I love very
much
our Republicans there's nothing wrong
with level-headed Republicans a large
amount of the people coming to see you
speak are not level-headed Republicans
the people I'm about to describe should
be the kind of scum that gets you riled
up when you hear that they dare to claim
to belong to the same group as you of
course you do now you do not announce
these people at least publicly because
they are your bread and butter
okay so already he's inviting me for
denouncing a group of people he hasn't
described yet so who are these nefarious
folks who are showing up to my speeches
supposedly these evil cruel people I
refuse to denounce he describes them
your fan base are people who have sent
death threats to the faculty of my
school simply because we ran out of
tickets for them to see you are they
because if so they should stop being
awful people don't send death threats to
faculty because you can't see one of my
shows but I don't have any evidence of
this and I have a fairly solid belief
that this kid doesn't have a lot of
evidence of this either like has he
actually tracked down the people who
wrote these nasty notes doesn't even
have access to those notes does your fan
base are the people that are making my
friends
lock themselves in their rooms on the
day that you're here for fear of their
lives
really my fan base because I'm fairly
certain that the death threats have been
all issued against me which is why I
have to travel with a large security
team and why they are now gonna spend a
bunch of money to bring police officers
out there that ain't my fans that's the
folks over nante fuh aren't susquehanna
rising which is one of these groups that
is claimed that they want to try to shut
down the event by the way I my full
expectation is that these are
Fairweather protesters it's really cold
outside it's snowing so if they show up
more power to them but what then he says
your fan base are the same people who
went through this campus last year
scrawling F free-world
F is a slur for gay people on the
sidewalk in drawing swastikas on
everything they see those are my fans
what in the world like where are you
getting this do they saw that they write
Shapiro and then a swastika like are you
an idiot
I wear a yarmulke I'm an Orthodox Jew I
was the leading victim of anti-semitism
on the on the right in well in all of
Jewish journalism in 2016 from the all
right what the hell are you talking
about and I refuse to condemn these
people again the whole goal of this
article is to make it seem like I am a
nefarious fellow because he can't
actually find anything nefarious that
I've done instead what he likes to do is
claim that I'm responsible for a bunch
of people who I've openly denounced for
years and then he says I find the last
one almost comically hypocritical given
the fact that you are a man of Jewish
faith what I don't condemn people who
draw swastikas what are you insane but
hey how many fans of Mya Annapolis do
you think are also big fans of any gay
people they meet in real life I'm not
gonna talk about Milo in his fans I've
been criticizing Milo for two years what
the hell they says this is not to say
you are responsible for the actions of
your fans right I'm not and also if they
do bad things I think they're Jack Jack
wagons cuz this is not even to say that
these people represent all of your fans
hell my little brother's a huge fan of
yours he's far from those monsters I
just described this is however to call
attention to the fact that if those
people are the ones supporting the
beliefs that you espouse maybe it's time
to re-evaluate those beliefs okay no
that's not how this works okay just
because they're a bunch of people who
may be fans of mine and may be jerks
does not mean that my belief system is
wrong it means that they're jerks there
are lots of jerks on all sides of the
aisle hey I would promise you the people
who are rioting across the country in
places like Ferguson and Baltimore our
fans of Barack Obama's policies does
that mean that Obama's policies are
necessarily wrong of course not in fact
when a Bernie Sanders supporter shot up
a congressional baseball game I was the
first one out there saying this is not
bird
Sandra's vault right why is it Bernie
Sanders's fault that there's a nutjob
who follows his ideas okay if the
implementation of your ideas causes
death if the implementation of your
ideas causes tyranny then we can talk
about whether your ideas are wrong but
just because some people who agree with
you happen to be bad human beings
doesn't mean that you are responsible
for their evil or that you're a bad
human being there's just a nasty form of
guilt by association that the left is
associated with and this is what they're
doing and this is what folks on the left
are doing increasingly late john oliver
attacking charlotte pence why she
happens to be related to the Vice
President of the United States David hog
suggesting that anyone who's a member of
the NRA is in favor of child death like
even when I was on CNN on Sunday with
brian Stelter there was one point where
Stelter said to me you know is it is it
really a set I'm saying you're biased
right CNN is biased against gun rights
and he said is it really a sin that we
want to stop gun violence the
implication being that if you're in
favor of gun rights you don't want to
stop gun violence and I said like what
what are you talking about what in the
world are you talking about but again
this is just another demonstration of
the radicalism that has overtaken so
much of the Democratic Party character
attacks are first on the list of things
to do rather than last on the list of
tactics to use Democratic radicalism has
really gotten extreme again these are
the same people who are endorsing keith
Ellison who's endorsing Louis Farrakhan
as same people claiming that my fans are
the problem are out there pretending
that the heads of the women's March can
hang out who was Farrakhan no problem
that keith Ellison who has nearly made
the head of the DNC is not a problem
either
speaking of keith Ellison by the way he
is a career-long anti-semite with
longtime associations with the Nation of
Islam's anti-semite extraordinaire Louis
Farrakhan while on Monday depending on
article at medium complaining about the
media's coverage of connections between
top Democrats in Farrakhan the Ellison's
article didn't take responsibility for
association with in defense of Farrakhan
instead he suggested that people like me
were attempting to drive a rift between
the Jewish and black communities which
is just like you endorsed in open
anti-semite because you said that he's
for black rights and then you accuse me
of driving a rift between black people
and Jewish people but this is the game
and this is the game that the left is
consistently playing it's quite insane
right Ellison says stuff like this he
says over the last few weeks some
political opponents have been pushing
the narrative that I'm somehow connected
to a man named Louis Farrakhan
not true really it's not true here's CNN
on Keith Alison's associations ACN nkf
I'll review of Ellison's past writings
and public statements during the late
1980s through the 1990s reveal his
decade-long involvement in the Nation of
Islam and his repeated defense of
Farrakhan and other radical black
leaders against accusations of
anti-semitism and columns and statements
to the press at CNN it ain't me
Nicki thelusson defended Kwame turn thou
be Stokely Carmichael in 1990 after
Carmichael made a speech stating quote
scientism must be destroyed in 1995
keith Ellison helped organize an event
and when she spoke before Kali to Abdul
Muhammad an anti-semite so rabid the
Nation of Islam kicked him out that same
year Ellison wrote quote Minister
Farrakhan is a role model for black
youth he is not an anti-semite he said
the same thing in 1997 according to the
Daily Caller Farrakhan attended at least
three meetings with Ellison okay three
including one in the last couple of
years now Farrakhan said on his own show
that he met Ellison in Farah Khan's
hotel room in December 2016 along with
representative Andre Carson okay but
that's not hateful what's hateful is to
point this out it really is an
astonishing thing and this shows the
radicalism of Democrats and it also
demonstrates why they have to make
character attacks because if they're
forced to defend their character on this
kind of stuff they're gonna fail every
single time okay so before we go any
further and I do want to talk about a
bevy of issues including the youth
suicide rates skyrocketing over the last
decade I want to talk about uber z'
magic self-driving cars but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
Wonder E they have a brand new podcast
it's called safe for work so we've been
endorsing a bunch of wondering podcasts
lately because they are all excellent
but this one is particularly good it's a
new podcast called safe for work it's
hosted by a former CMO of Nike and chief
management officer of Nike and a former
lawyer
they take your questions and your calls
and give you advice on how to find
happiness in the workplace so most of us
are doing something we're not fans of
and that's work to be honest sometimes
works in that bad when sometimes you're
just having one of those days and the
place you need to go for advice is the
safe for work podcast and that's what
it's all about so go subscribe listen
too safe for work on Apple podcasts or
wherever you're listening to this one
right now or head to wonder AFM slash up
here oh that's Wonder with Y dot F M
slash Shapiro again there are issues
that come up at work every day these
guys are experts to former CMO of Nike
and a former lawyer and they take your
questions and cause it's amusing it's
entertaining and it's really informative
so check it out again you know when
you're over
this podcast you get all the political
information need but then you need to
know how to succeed at work that's what
will help you do it go over and
subscribe and listen to safe for work on
Apple podcast I've listened to it myself
it really is terrific wand radio FM
slash appear oh that's wonder with yfm
slash Shapiro okay so a couple of other
topics that I think are worthwhile
discussing but first you're gonna have
to go over to daily wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you get a
subscription to daily wire comm that
means that you get the rest of the show
live means you get the rest of the
clayvin show live the rest of the Noles
show live you get to be part of my
mailbag it also means then when you get
the annual subscription you get the very
best in beverage vessels the leftist
tiers hot or cold tumbler it is right
here it's so great then I can make it
disappear at will Wow okay will reappear
on Thursday magically I won't tell you
how that happened but you can get it
when you're not on the road you can get
it and by becoming an annual subscriber
for 99 bucks a year that it's cheaper
than the monthly subscription please
check it out that helps support the site
it helps make sure we can bring you the
show every day also if you just want to
listen later subscribe over at iTunes or
YouTube or SoundCloud please leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest core and
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so in other news the CDC is is
issuing a stunning report about youth
suicide and it does say something about
where we stand as a country according to
the Centers for Disease Control youth
suicide is in the middle of a
precipitous really frightening
skyrocketing rate in suicide between
2006 and 2016 suicides by white kids
between 10 and 17 jumped 70 percent 7-0
black kids are less likely than white
kids to kill themselves this is true
generally black folks are less likely to
commit suicide than white folks but
their suicide rate actually jumped even
more it jumped 77% the blaze points out
that CNN reported last year the suicide
rate among girls between the ages of 15
and 19 rose to a 40-year high in 2015
and it's not just young people Tom Simon
is a CDC report author and he said quote
we know that overall in the u.s. we're
seeing increases in suicide rates across
all age groups as of 2016
suicide levels were at 30-year high so
what the hell is going on right we have
material prosperity so they're a bunch
of theories about why the suicide rate
has been skyrocketing theory number one
is that the suicide rate has been rising
because the economy was bad in 2007-2008
and the evidence for that is really not
there because what you would have
expected is that the suicide rate would
mirror the economy economic decline in
2007-2008 would go like this would
actually be reverse right it can't go
like this suicide rate would go like
this and then as the economy started to
rise the suicide rate would start going
down that's not what happened at all the
suicide rate has continued to rise then
there are people who blame the rise of
suicide on drugs
I particularly opioids but according to
a study from the National Institute of
drug abuse drinking smoking and drug use
may be at the lowest level seen in
decades among teenagers so it's actually
going down so what exactly is happening
I think that the solution is is not
something that a lot of folks on the
Left are going to like but I think that
it's pretty obvious if you look at polls
on human happiness if you look at polls
on people finding meaning in their lives
I mean like cosmic meaning in their
lives
it is highly correlative with religious
practice so according to the Atlantic
right not a right-wing source they cited
a study in Psychological Science it said
this quote the researchers found that
this factor of religiosity mediated the
relationship between a country's wealth
and the perceived meaning in its
citizens lives meaning that it was the
presence of religion that largely
accounted for the gap between money and
meaning people in the West largely find
find meaning in materialism this is true
for people on the left and the right
Marxists say that all human meaning can
be found in rectifying income inequality
a lot of folks on these sort of
libertarian rights suggest that material
wealth and prevalence of human freedoms
provide people meaning that has not held
true throughout human history so this
study analyzed a bunch of other factors
education fertility rates individualism
social support to see if they could
explain the findings in the end only one
factor mattered it was religion in other
words people need meaning and purpose in
life our focus on materialism on both
sides is not going to fill this gap
that's been left by God when God died so
did a piece of us right this isn't the
problem that can be cured by
redistributing X boxes there's a problem
the human sould now this doesn't mean
you have to head on over to the church
and they have to become a deeply
religious member of an organized
religious sect it does mean you have to
put aside spiritual but not religious
spiritual doesn't come with action
points okay people need action points
and people are notoriously bad at
defining their own meaning I know
there's been this moral relativistic
streak that is characterized
post-enlightenment thought in the West
that there's good and there's bad but
it's really up to you and is the line
from city slickers and city slickers
Billy Crystal's going through a midlife
crisis and he goes out with his friends
Daniel Stern and Bruno Kirby all the way
out to the desert know when he gets out
to the desert he meets up with curly and
curly is a played by Jack Palance and
Jack Palance gives him the meaning of
life he says the meaning of life is one
thing and then he dives before he can
say what the one thing is what is the
one thing and Palance basically says
well that's for you to find out well
except that human beings aren't really
bad at this human beings are not good at
finding out what their meaning is human
beings need to be told that they have a
special meaning in the universe a
special place before God they're made in
God's image they have intense value and
that even the mundane things they do in
life have a deeper lasting impact beyond
themselves right that people do need
that and it's it's really weird to me
that so many people on the Left deny
this I understand they think that
religion has been an obstacle to human
growth which I don't see the evidence
for you know I know that they believe
that that religion has been an obstacle
to the scientific development which
again has not been true historically
speaking there are times when religion
has been an obstacle that overall
religion is actually in a spur for most
of human history at least in in the West
that said the I explained all of us in
my upcoming book actually that said
there's a lack of meaning that is
in American society and I think it's
coming to a head right now now speaking
of lack of meaning and and devastating
events today there was another school
shooting this time in Maryland high
school and this one was actually rather
instructive because a resource officer
fired at the high school shooter who was
fatally shot
so three individuals including the
shooter were shot according to a local
reporter Peggy Fox Sheriff Tim Cameron
confirmed that it should incur this
morning in a hallway by a great mental
student who's eventually engaged by an
armed resource officer the shooter
reportedly fired at a female student and
another student was hit an armed school
resource officer that engaged the
shooter with a firearm so this is what
should have happened at Parkland instead
it happened in Maryland and prevented
further death this does give the lie to
the idea that a good guy with a gun
cannot stop a bad guy with a gun so good
for the school resource officer for
doing the right thing again disproving
the argument that guns are inherently
bad now speaking of technologies that
have been blamed as inherently bad well
they're not inherently bad there's a lot
of hubbub in the last couple of days
over this autonomous uber so here is the
story
apparently there's a woman who was
killed because she was why she basically
she's a homeless woman in Arizona and
she jumped in front of a car the car was
in autonomous driving uber and now this
has created all sorts of problems for
uber there's been a lot of talk about
pulling these autonomously burrs off the
market that somehow this is going to
make the roads safer okay here's the
story though here's the rest of the
story according to the Daily Mail the
female driver who was in control that
self driving uber when it hit and killed
a homeless woman in Arizona is a
convicted felon who claims the victim
stepped out in front of his car suddenly
giving her no time to try to avoid her
Rafaela Vasquez was responsible for the
vehicle when struck in lane Herzberg 49
on Sunday night in Tempe Arizona she
previously spent four years in prison
for armed robbery and falsifying
documents was hired by uber anyway on
Sunday night the car was in self-driving
mode when it struck Herzberg Vasquez was
supposed to act as a safety driver and
take control of the vehicle if anything
went wrong she told police that her Berg
could spend time in prison for drug
offenses stepped out in front of her
with a bicycle carrying multiple
shopping bags and she had no time to
brake before it hit her but she was
traveling at 40 miles per hour at the
time well within the 40 mile 45 mile per
hour speed limit she insisted she was
alert but nothing could have been done
to stop the crash the police basically
agreed her story
supported by footage of the cameras
fitted at the front and back of the
Volvo SUV the reason that I'm bringing
up this story is because there's a lot
of alarmism about the machines are going
to kill us all there's been a lot of
talk about we're all going to die
because of the rise of the machines and
all this sort of nonsense this is not
going to be true okay there are 40,000
Auto mode auto mobile deaths last year
virtually all of them or due to human
error machines are better at this stuff
than human beings are now I know there's
been a lot of talk about truck drivers
gonna go out of business and so many
people won't be able to drive anymore
and what are we gonna do but all this
really is in essence is Luddite ISM what
happens this lady is terrible but it
sounds like it would happen whether it
was a human driver or an automated
driver again machines are very good at
these types of things and the and the
roads will be a lot safer when there are
more machines on them rather than more
human beings because people are
notoriously bad at driving they just
suck at it
plus we're texting anyway so better that
we should be texting while not driving
then that we should be texting and
driving at the same time okay so but now
it's time for me to do some things I
like and some things that I hate so a
quick thing I like so this movie I had a
chance to watch a couple of days ago I
there's no doubt after watching this
movie the Margot Robbie should have won
Best Actress over Frances McDormand who
I thought was overrated in three
billboards the movie was I Tania it's
quite good it's it's quite a good film
it's quite an effective film and and
Margot Robbie really connect which is
it's always a it's always sort of a
shock when a woman who I believe started
off as a model and something a very good
actress but she's actually a terrific
actress so here she is in I Tania Tania
tell the truth
[Music]
there's no such thing as truth everyone
has their own truth I was the best
figure skater in the world at one point
in time
call out a clean skate stop talking to
her that girl is your enemy Jeff was my
first date ever and my mom came so the
film is actually quite good it's really
effective and they tried to turn it into
a critique of American life and and how
viewers treat ice skating they want all
these these women not to have real lives
and all the rest of the sort of stuff
the real story is Tonya Harding had a
wonderful mother and also had a horrible
ex-husband and her ex-husband according
to the movie at least plan the hit on
Nancy Kerrigan basically himself along
with an idiot friend of his it's hard to
watch but it is entertaining so it's it
feels like Goodfellas I mean that's sort
of the feel of the movie even though the
two movies have nothing else in common
except for a very very good soundtrack
there's there's a bunch of great songs
on the soundtrack too I Tanya so while
we're checking out much better than the
shape of water I would have to do a full
critique of shape of water tomorrow
because I watched it once I thought it
sucked and I was on the plane yesterday
and I thought maybe I'll try this again
and see if I really think it sucks I
mean I just won Best Picture
maybe I got this all wrong I was wrong
the movie is so bad I wanted to walk off
the plane it is that bad a movie it is
in my in my opinion one of the five
worst movies I have ever seen in my
entire life
I will do a full critique of it tomorrow
because it's just absolute hogwash
garbage yuck oh yeah
in them great art direction and the
script is written by an angry sjw
ten-year-old and crayon it's just
garbage okay time for a quick thing that
I hate okay so Jim Carrey who has lost
his mind or whatever it was left of it
he also has decided that he's going to
go into portrait painting so he painted
this portrait of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and here's what it looks like yeah
obviously he he loves Sarah Huckabee
Sanders very clearly so he he said quote
this is the portrait of a so-called
Christian whose only purpose in life is
to lie for the wicked monstrous just
just wonderful I'm sure the Jim Carrey
himself is wonderful Christian and in a
great tribute to two people of religion
everywhere you know the nastiness that's
inherent in this is pretty obvious this
kind of art is fairly typical but again
it's all about the people you disagree
with politically must be bad human
beings if he wants to say that she
bad because she lies for the president I
guess that's his you know it's his
prerogative and he could then make a
case for why that is the case you know I
don't think it's good to lie for the
president either but I get the feeling
that whether or not
Sarah Huckabee Sanders were telling
untruths on behalf of the president he
would've said the same thing about Dana
Perino because this is just what the
left has become it's all about character
attacks and maligning other people's
character as opposed to actually
standing up for an agenda okay we'll be
back here at tomorrow tomorrow we're
gonna be broadcasting from Washington DC
in a very special place I will tell you
about it when we get there I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing